the first stationary bike was developed
by a London physician in the late 18th
century to exercise the joints of
patients suffering from gout Rheumatic
disorders or other
afflictions the modern stationary bike
is all about helping people stay fit to
prevent
illnesses on this stationary bike
magnets linked to the flywheel create
tension that causes the cyclist to push
harder making the workout truly an
uphill
battle production starts with steel
tubing for the
base a probe locates the center of the
tubing this reference point allows a
computerized laser cutter to find the
exact spots to cut assembly
holes with the assembly holes cut the
laser slices the tubing to the correct
length an automated system retrieves the
part and transfers it to a holding
area a worker inserts screws in the base
part which will attach it to the main
frame he pipes sealant around the
screws another worker now arranges the
three tubular base Parts in a welding
fixture and clamps them in
place the fixture revolves and meets up
with a robotic
welder the robot welds the three parts
together this completes the base of the
stationary
bike the bike's main frame has been
configured on the other side of the
welding fixture the robot welds these
parts together the fixture rotates to
serve up another base assembly to the
robot and the worker collects the welded
main frame from the reverse
side he grinds the welded seam smooth
and gets rid of Burrs on the
steel workers sand blast the metal wash
it and apply
primer after grounding the main frame
another worker sprays electrostatically
charged resin and pigment onto it once
it's baked on this powder coat will
provide a protective
finish at another station a 55ton press
punches holes into posts for the bike's
handlebar and
seat the holes are for adjusting the
height of these
parts next up is the casting for
mounting the handle bar to the
post using another press the worker
entrenches the top of the post in the
casting he Taps the casting with a
rubber mallet to tweak the installation
and sets the assembly
aside at another station a worker
arranges numerous seat posts in tight
alignment he drapes a stencil of
sequential lettering on top of the
post he dips an etching wand in a chem
chemical solution and then moves it over
the letters five
times this burns the letters into the
steel providing markers for height
adjustment an assembler drives a wedge
into one of the bike's two crank arms to
create a hole that the axle will fit
into he checks the depth of the hole
with a gauge he inserts the end of the
axle in the hole and using a press
pushes it into
place
he measures the hole from the other side
of the crank arm and confirms that the
axle has been set to the correct
depth he then bolts the assembly to a
precise
torque he locks the crank arm assembly
in a
lathe he slips a foam sleeve over the
axle to protect it from shards of flying
metal as a tool machines the part of the
crank arm that will ultimately hold the
bike's pulley
another member of the team now assembles
bearings to a wheel hub he slides two
bearings with a spacer in a
press he heats the Hub in an oven
causing the metal to
expand the machine presses the Hub
sandwich together as the Hub cools it
shrinks for a tight fit to the
bearings he installs a painting clip in
the hub to also keep it
together next up are the holders for the
magnets that create resistance on the
flywheel a worker places each one in a
fixture to inspect the
dimensions he then checks the strength
of the magnets in a
tester and satisfied he inserts two in
each
holder this metal cage pulled into
position by the magnets completes the
magnetic field field stay tuned for more
on the making of This stationary
bike the assembler installs the magnetic
resistance unit so that it swings from a
bracket on the main frame this bracket
also holds the computer
board he mounts the aluminum flywheel to
the axle sliding it between the magnets
and the tension device he caps the
flywheel Hub and secures the cap with
screws
the torsion spring equipped cover
completes the stationary bike's tension
[Music]
system he assembles the crank arm and
Axle to the bike and installs a bearing
then the bike moves on to the next
station another worker places an
alignment tool on the back
axle he Loops an elastic belt with
grooves around the small pulley on the
flywheel and around the larger crank arm
pulley linking the two
he inserts another tool into the crank
arm and turns it to better wrap the belt
around the large crank
pulley he then removes both installation
[Music]
tools he installs four flat bushings in
The Handlebar post these bushings make
it possible for The Handlebar to be
raised and
lowered he applies a decal with the
height
indicators made of a rugged synthetic
material the decal encases three sides
of the metal post and this protects it
from
[Music]
abrasion he bolts the second crank arm
to the axle and torqus it to the
specified
[Music]
tension next up is the seat assembly he
slides the seat stem into the post and
tightens the adjustment knob to lock it
in place
he inserts The Handlebar post into the
bike frame and Fishes the gear cable and
communication wires through
it he secures The Handlebar post with
the adjustment
knob he connects the communication line
to the resistance system's computer
board he links the gear cable to the
resistance system and tests its
functionality satisfied he tightens a
nut at the side to secure the
cable another worker installs a plastic
cover on the
drivetrain this will protect the cyclus
legs from the pulley system and shield
the metal components from human
sweat for added moisture protection she
applies sealer around a welded
reinforcement on the bike
frame she then encases the fork of the
bike with more molded
plastic bolts secure the casings to the
bike
she now places a magnetized microphone
on the axle and Spins the flywheel at a
high
RPM this is a test the bike must operate
noiselessly and the decel meter confirms
the noise level is
negligible she also feels the frame for
unwanted
vibrations she now sets the location of
the magnetic resistance mechanism using
using a special
tool this calibrates the resistance so
that the handlebar computer can find it
and display the resistance setting
during
cycling another member of the team then
applies thread loocking adhesive to the
screw holes in the crank
arms he screws the pedals tightly to the
crank arms and torqus them to a specific
setting the worker aligns the four bolt
holes on the front frame to the bolts on
the base and secures them with cap
[Music]
nuts